hi there steve kaufman i just wanted to
put this brief uh introduction in here
before my video today
because as you know i'm in the middle of
my arabic challenge i'm enjoying it i i
don't necessarily always feel that my
speaking is improving
uh maybe i spoke better before when i
was focusing on the many stories but i
am a cube accumulating vocabulary and
enjoying my my podcast but when i
started on the challenge back in early
september i had a conversation with john
filson an american who has spent a lot
of time in iraq
and it was very interesting and i just
thought it would be useful here to show
you that interview where he talks about
iraq his experience there and we talk
about the differences between iraqi
arabic and modern standard arabic
arabic the language the culture the
history is a wonderful experience i very
much recommend it to anyone and but i'm
staying on my standard arabic uh for now
at any rate okay here's the video
[Music]
okay today we're going to talk about
arabic because i've been learning arabic
in fact for the 90-day challenge i've
decided to put my persian aside and
focus on arabic and today i have the
pleasure of talking to john filson
who has a very rich background of
experience in arabic and we're going to
talk about the wonders of learning
arabic and all of its different
variations
and
at the end or in the middle at some
point we're going to try and speak to
each other john is a fluent speaker of
iraqi arabic i am a struggling speaker
of fusa and we're going to see how far
we go remember if you like these videos
please subscribe there's a little bell
there if you you know tick it you're
going to get notifications and if you
like learning languages the way i do
come and visit us at link hello john can
you briefly tell us about yourself and
your background in arabic
okay and and we will as i said we're
gonna experiment a little bit uh because
it's all a mystery to me i'm discovering
the language but
the one thing that i find with arabic is
is first of all
you know you've got english and chinese
and spanish that are recognized as these
widely spoken languages but arabic
there's like 400 million people who
speak arabic
and what i have found you know before i
started into arabic i heard well you
know each language is different and
stuff
and i see the unity i've listened to
lebanese movies and egyptian movies and
i was in morocco and yeah they're all
different and different difficult to
understand but you can see how they're
all part of one and and maybe that's the
advantage of having studied fusa that i
see the extent to which they're so
recognizably part of that one large very
rich uh language community
have you have you spoken to people from
lebanon and from egypt and to what the
greek or from the gulf
iraq is almost the gulf anyway to
understand you understand them
right
right right
leave it off yeah
right
yep
i'll walk it yeah
right right
well you know and that's very similar to
say uh mandarin and cantonese if you're
into more serious you know than use or
anything like that it's essentially the
same words pronounced differently but
it's the same words whereas the
day-to-day chit is going to have a lot
more different words in it uh we'll
probably try to show perhaps the the
arab world
you know the from the levant call it you
know syria lebanon palestine
uh egypt back into iraq we'll throw a
map up hopefully we can get this up
there down to you know mauritania and
sudan i mean it's a vast area where
people speak arabic and the other thing
to remember about arabic too is while
islam is a very big part of our of the
arabic culture today there are lots of
christian arabs uh
the jews in israel when i was there
there was a jewish iraqi wedding it was
arabic like everything about the way
they behaved and the language they spoke
those are also arabs so you have jewish
arabs christian arabs and of course
muslim arabs and and in jordan when i
visited petra that this is a wonderful
world heritage site that predates islam
so so the arab world is not limited to
islam even though of quran and islam is
not limited to the arabic world but
there's a lot more there
to discover
in terms of culture and so forth
[Music]
right
well that's that's an amazing thing if
you were in iraq you'll have to tell us
where you were but you're basically in
the cradle of civilization where
everything started
and i learned through my persian
learning that
large portions of iraq were part of
persia at different times
that baghdad apparently then word back
that is a persian origin so you know
there's a lot of interrelations there i
mean with the kurds and you got arabs in
per in iran and and so it's you know and
that's part of the joys of learning
these languages is to discover the
history and the culture and and where
were you located in in iraq
okay
but but also in turkish and greek
dolmades or whatever they call them you
know
right
right yeah
right
right
okay
right
right
mm-hmm
do some of those christians speak
aramaic
right right
right
is aramaic a little closer to hebrew
right
right
right
okay
okay okay
right
right
right
wow i mean there's just so much to
discover
and i mean it is a multi-ethnic
multi-cultural
multi-religious uh
even just in terms of sunni and shia
uh community with this tremendous amount
of history and stuff like that
um
should we try to speak some arabic and i
have to confess that i don't
your approach to learning it is quite
different from mine because you are in
amongst them speaking it and i'm far
away from any arabic speakers and i just
listen to these podcasts now i've moved
through my mini stories to where i
listen to podcasts that i have
transcribed and i follow events in the
middle east
you know the arab the at least the uae
and israeli agreement and so i they all
argue
did you find in iraq if you have a panel
discussion on radio or television they
all speak at the same time
[Laughter]
for sure
[Music]
[Music]
vancouver
right
right
right
okay
uh
[Music]
nurses
[Music]
what's touchy
tattoo
okay i couldn't figure out what you were
talking about
okay yeah
yeah turkey
[Music]
okay
mm-hmm okay
okay
some of it what throws me off i you know
like sometimes they say okay sometimes
it's a cho and you were saying that
something about learning through reading
and you're speaking
the trouble is i'll run through some
where i understand the words and i hit
pitchy or hit something that makes no
sense and i find that and i think we've
kind of demonstrated arabic is i love it
i think your accent i can't judge iraqi
arabic but it sounds really authentic to
me
so the problem always even when i listen
to these podcasts if i get if i can be
in a stretch where i understand it and
then i get a few words in a row that i
don't understand then i lose the thread
and so that's what's difficult and
that's why you kind of have to have
quite a few words actually in order to
be able to follow along uh just out of
curiosity is iraqi closer to gulf arabic
or closer to you know syrian or whatever
because they have neighbors on both
sides you got kuwait or whatever on the
one side and you've got syria on the
other side or jordan i guess
right
right
right
right
right
yeah okay well listen uh
very good you know i i was not able i i
say but you know if i were to go to iraq
but you understand me better than i
understand you
right right
right
right
right
okay all right
what i understood okay
okay sure enough sure enough
tour
[Music]
um
okay all right
okay
oh can okay kinda okay
um
same word
okay
uh necessarily i forgot like this after
camila forgot the word right yes
you lived in mountains alone
um
[Music]
we'll give you a childish son or
daughter yeah
it's difficult
is to go right
this is which is not in not in fusa but
it's in in lebanese and in yeah okay
you're not married
so you told your sister
[Music]
what's hedgiar again
okay i don't know that word okay
okay
right right
what's here
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
hmm
what's alas
okay okay
oh yeah
alasas yeah
okay yeah yeah
okay
right okay
okay so you went to the monk
anybody who understands iraqi is having
a ball but everybody else is lost in
this but you visited this monk in the
mountains and if he
bows his head three times or uh towards
a rock or something then you'll
have a child and daughter or son you
weren't married at the time so you
called your sister and asked her and she
didn't have she and her husband
obviously they're married they didn't
have any kids but then they she had to
decide she hadn't thought about it but
okay uh i want to i don't remember what
she wanted a daughter or a son but she
didn't end up getting one but you did
you got two
basically that's the story yeah
so
right
okay
oh to you you you have to bow to the
rock
yeah
oh slide down the face with rock okay
okay
right
okay
right
right yeah yeah
right
right but yeah you were trying to
god hadn't factored in modern cell phone
technology
in the story okay well listen
thank you for all of that and uh
it was fun and uh we should do this
again but in the meantime you know uh i
should point out that john has a uh does
a lot of work to help uh you know iraqis
other arab speakers learn english that's
the main thrust of his website and i've
said you know we want to obviously
improve our arabic service our service
either teaching arabic or our interface
in arabic
for arabs arabic speakers who are
learning other languages and link and we
do have the contribute page at link so
that if there are arabic speakers
who can either contribute content
stories like the story you just told
in any form of arabic because we have
now i think we have you know standard
arab but we have egyptian we have uh
levantine
uh
most welcome and if we can
perhaps work with you in some of your
contacts in iraq who want to improve
their language skills and maybe we can
help them out in some way because i
think iraq is a fabulous country with
tremendous history and
from what i've seen too quite a variety
of landscapes we think it's just one
great big desert which isn't the case
and a country that's had a tremendous
amount of misfortune over the last
little while and we obviously wish them
all the best so john thank you very much
[Music]